وفي اوكرانيا حاليا حول 25 الف محطه
استقبال ارضيه في جميع انحاء البلاد
الفارق لا يزال كبيرا بالعدد مع ما ارسل
لايران لكن يبدو ان صوت الايرانيين
سيستمروا بالوصول الى العالم
لدى ستارلينج حاليا اكثر من 2000 قمر
اصطناعي صغير تدور حول الارض في مدار
منخفض اي على ارتفاع بضع مئات من
الكيلومترات لاتاحه الوصول الى الانترنت
لسكان المناطق الواقعه اسفل لها لكن كيف
تعمل هذه التقنيه
للتمكن من الاتصال بهذه الاقمار
الاصطناعيه يتعين وجوده محطات استقبال
ارضيه توزع كل منها او توزع كل منها
الخدمه للمستخدمين بواسطه اجهزه توجيه
راوتر
الغايه او الهدف ايصال خدمه انترنت رخيصه
وسريعه وايضا ان يقطع الى المسك حصه من
الارباح ارباح قطاع الاتصالات العالميه ما
سيسمح لشركه بربح ما يتراوح بين 30 و 50
مليار دولار سنويا اقمار ماسك صناعيه
لخدمه الانترنت تتميز بان مدارها حول
الارض اقرب من ممثلاتها للدول او الشركات
الاخرى ما سيقلل من انقطاع او تاخر
الانترنت لدى المستقبلين
ايضا سترتبط اقمار ستار لينك مع بعضها
بشعاع الليزر ما سيجعل الناس قادرين على
استخدام الانترنت بشكل مستمر وان تغير
القمر الذي يكون وقتها فوق المنزل لكن
الامر لا يخلو من جوانب سلبيه ايضا
فازدحام المدار بالاقمار الصناعيه قد يزيد
من صعوبه رؤيه الاجسام او الكويكبات التي
قد تصطدم بالارض اضافه بذلك قد تعيق
الاقمار الصناعيه البحث عن كواكب او ثقوب
سوداء جديده اما الامر الاخضر فهو تلبد
مدار الارض بالشظايا في حال ارتطام
الاقمار الصناعيه ببعضها البعض او تصادم
تضايا المتطايره ببعضها
ايه
[موسيقى]